it seems clear that today faith is
thriving in many parts of the world it
seems also clear that faith is not just
thriving but at various faiths are
increasingly finding it important to
insert themselves into public realm it
is equally clear that the idea of
democracy is popular in the world today
just about all parts of the globe and
then the question becomes what is the
relationship between faith and faith
which refuses to be simply private and
the idea and the practice of democracy
this question is particularly
significant as we live in an
increasingly pluralistic world so that
various policies themselves are
increasingly internally pluralistic
various worldviews vie for attention and
express interests and needs and then the
question becomes how does one negotiate
between the claims of one faiths to be
the faith to be heard and the democratic
process this is the topic for our
discussion today under what condition if
at all is it permitted for faith to
express itself and be brought to bear in
the public realm what ways can be
designed so that that faiths insertion
into the public realm is part and parcel
of regular democratic process this is a
significant issue both because of the
vibrancy of faith in the world today and
because of the attractiveness of the
idea of democracy